this video is sponsored by squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
hey guys it's max
in front of me i have the brand new
razer book razer's first
non-gaming laptop and we're gonna
compare it to the brand new m1 powered
macbook pro now both these have very
similar specs
and i'll go ahead and link both down in
the video description
in this video we're not only going to
compare the design the performance
fan noise and heat but we're also going
to test the speakers
webcam and microphones photo editing and
one test that we haven't done in any of
our m1 comparisons that you won't want
to miss
prices are also similar but we're going
to talk about that at the end and a few
key differences now let's go ahead and
close these up and let's first talk
about the design
the macbook pro has its iconic standard
design that hasn't changed for a long
time
it's slim it's lightweight and the razer
it also looks kind of like a copycat of
apple
but it is super premium it feels solid
the edges are also curved but they're a
little bit more squared off
we have aluminum all around it feels
fantastic and along with that we have a
couple vents here at the bottom you guys
might be able to see
some fans through that whereas the
macbook pro has no vents on the bottom
so you're not going to be able to block
it if it's on your lap
but with these vents we should get some
good airflow into the machine
and i'm excited to see how the 11 gen
processor performs
in this chassis the inside is also very
solid there's
very little flex on the deck and overall
this is the best built
windows laptop that i've ever tested
they improved the speaker grills here
it feels fantastic i just have one
complaint
the macbook opens up easily with one
hand and
the razer the cutout is just way too
small and you have to use two hands to
open it as far as battery and chargers i
have to say
finally we have a nice slim charging
brick thank you razer
this one's 65 watts compared to apple's
61.
as you guys could see it's a little bit
longer but it's quite a bit smaller
now with that i do have to say i like
the little design where you have this
little plug
you don't have to use the cable like you
do with razors but both of them are usb
type-c
and this one is really nicely made now
as far as the batteries
the razer laptop's slightly smaller and
has a slightly smaller battery at 55
watt hours compared to 58
but we're gonna talk about real-world
battery life at the end of this video
as far as ports the mac just has two
they're all
on the left hand side usb4 and
thunderbolt capable
and then we have a headphone jack
thankfully at least for now
and the razer absolutely smokes it on
the left hand side we have a thunderbolt
4 port
standard usb headphone jack and on the
other side we have another thunderbolt 4
hdmi 2.0 and a micro sd card slot
another thing i love about the razer is
that we have
windows hello so as soon as you open it
bam right there
it logs you in the mac does have an
always on mode
instantly on you don't have to wait but
you do have to use touch id it's not as
convenient
let's get into keyboard and trackpads
the macbook has
apple's magic keyboard it feels
fantastic reliability has also been
really good as far as the razer book the
keys also feel
really nice they used to have really bad
keyboards
but this is a really big upgrade i'm
also really surprised by how bright the
rgb
backlighting is on the razer it's almost
blindingly bright
but you need that with the white keycaps
whereas with the mac
i have a maxed out you can't really tell
but at night it's definitely there
if i had to choose which keyboard is
better i would choose the mac but most
people will be
very happy with either one of these the
macbook also has the touch bar
above the keyboard with your shortcuts
you can customize it
let me know what you think about the
touch bar down in the comments section
below
and now let's move down a little bit to
the track pads the razer book
has a really nice large trackpad but the
max is bigger
the mac also feels a little better it's
not a true diving board design it's
magnetic you can customize it
it's the best on the market with that
said i've been playing with the razors
it also works really well and even
though it is a diving board design they
have done a fantastic
job their track pads used to be garbage
now
this one is definitely usable i gotta
say the razer book is starting to shape
up to be
my favorite windows laptop as long as it
gets the speakers correct and the webcam
which we will test in just a bit but
first let me give a shout out to the
sponsor of this video
squarespace if you've been thinking
about making your own website
squarespace is seriously the best way to
go we've built multiple websites and you
can too
with literally no web making experience
you just choose a template customize
blocks of text and images and
easily move them around it's incredibly
simple it's affordable and rs have been
running for years now
bringing in new clients thanks to its
built-in seo tools so whether you need a
website for a small business or for
literally anything else
go to squarespace.commaxtech or use the
custom link down below
to get a free trial with no credit card
needed and when you're ready to launch
use our coupon code to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain let me quickly cover
the displays both are about 13.3 13.4
inches and thankfully
this razer now has a 16 by 10 aspect
ratio
which is so much better for a 13 inch
laptop now as far as resolution the
macbook has 4.1 million pixels
compared to 2.3 million pixels so about
80
more pixels and yes you can tell when
you're looking at fine text
that it is sharper it is more detailed
now i do have to mention that you
can get a 4k display with the razer it
just costs quite a bit more
and it also affects battery life which
we'll talk about at the end of this
video
and that the razer's displays are
actually
touchscreen which is convenient for some
tasks now we also have a difference in
color
accuracy the macbook can display dci p3
colors where the razer cannot so if
you're serious about color grading
photo editing the macbook is better
comparing the brightness as you can tell
with that top camera both are
very very similar at about 500 nits and
that is fantastic
because the razers used to be about 300
they'd be quite dim and hard to see
when you're outside and as far as
viewing angles the razer is actually
better as you can see with our side
angle as far as contrast the macbook
is once again better but interestingly
as far as reflectivity the razer is
slightly
better and it makes me think is this
displayed the same exact one that's in
the brand new xps
because it acts and looks exactly like
it other than dci p3 support
so finally razer also fixed the
reflectivity that is awesome
both of these laptops have 720p webcams
but it's interesting that the razer
looks to have four microphones above its
screen
so i'm interested to see how the mic is
gonna perform let's take a listen
this is the microphone and webcam
quality in a fairly well
lit room from the m1 macbook pro
this is the microphone and webcam
quality of the razer book
in a fairly well-lit room and now it's
time to compare the speakers both these
laptops have some grills on the sides of
the keyboard
but the razer has this thx label on here
it has some credibility
in the past the razer laptops sucked
when it came to sound
so hopefully it's a lot better put on a
pair of headphones and let's take a
listen
go ahead and let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below and i
just have to say
i was sitting here shaking my head why
does this have a thx logo on it i don't
know
because i haven't heard sound this bad
and this quiet
since the last time i reviewed a razer
laptop
it is unfortunate my iphone 12 mini
sounds about the same volume
but it actually has more bass than this
laptop that is such a shame and now
let's get into performance i'm going to
start out by testing the ssds
now our macbook pro has a 512 gig ssd
compared to 256
on the razer but that is how they're
configuring this
spec so let's go ahead and run our speed
test here
wow all right very nice job razer
the right speed is about the same the
read speed is actually faster on the
razer even
has a smaller ssd now with that you can
actually swap out the ssd because it is
a m.2
whereas with the macbook pro it is
soldered in so you need to buy
however much you're going to need for
the future right away next we are going
to be doing a web browser test and so
many of us spend
a lot of time on the web i have chrome
opened on both of these to make it fair
let's go ahead and get started here we
have our scores and the macbook pro
is about 30 faster snappier quicker when
it comes to general web browsing
but with that said this is the highest
i've ever seen
any windows laptop or any intel based
laptop that is an excellent score
definitely not a slouch and now let's go
ahead and test out
the processors we have intel's best 11
gen
compared to apple's m1 chip both 16 gigs
of ram
let's go ahead and get started all right
guys we have our results and
this is actually impressive we have 15
34
for the razer that's actually better
than the dell that's the best we've ever
seen on an intel mac
but the macbook with the m1 is still
about 15
faster in a single core now of course
the multi-core score we have an
even bigger difference the macbook here
is 40 percent
faster now with that said that is with
both of the laptops
plugged in if we go ahead and unplug
both of these
the razer actually will go into a
balanced power mode
not only in the window settings but also
in razer's software under the
performance mode
you no longer have the full performance
ultimate performance mode only
battery saver or default and you cannot
change that so i'm running this test one
more time to see what kind of
performance do you get
if you are unable to plug in or you just
don't want to
wow okay this is a first
the razer actually got a higher score
when it was unplugged with multi-core
you guys see you're about 260 points
higher
all the other windows laptops with
tension 11 gen processors
they scored a lot lower but not this one
the macbook
actually got slightly higher score in
multicore as well of course in the macro
pros
also more powerful now what i'm very
interested in
do we get a similar result at least
similar performance when you're really
pushing the system and photo video
editing and cinebench
because geekbench it only tests out some
very simple tasks even with multi-core
we're going to check that out here in
just a bit and now let's go ahead and
compare the graphics
this razer book has intel's best xe
graphics the highest end version of it
and of course
the macbook has apple's m1 graphics the
eight core version i'm gonna go ahead
and run
geekbench five's compute test here it's
finished and it looks like the m1
macbook pro
is about 15 16 faster now we are using
metal if i was to use opencl it'd be a
little bit slower but still
faster than the razer but of course all
the mac apps are using metal now so
i have to say that this is fairly close
and this is actually the highest score
that i've seen
on a windows 13-inch ultrabook and now
i'm gonna unplug both of these
and i'm curious will the razer perform
the same as it did
when it was plugged in just like with a
cpu test we have a result
and oh my goodness once again
we have the same score actually is this
slightly higher than the last one let me
take a look
actually slightly higher on battery
power
man this is other than speakers the best
windows laptop as far as ultrabooks it
maintains its performance even though
it's in balance mode
that is so so refreshing to see of
course the macbook is
still a little bit more powerful but
let's go ahead and shut this down here
and let's do a more serious gaming test
more
real world with gfx bench i'm running
the 1440p
aztec ruins high tier off screen test so
resolution won't make any difference
between these machines
the mac started up much faster
than the razer all right and wow
i was not expecting this the macbook
scored 79.5
frames per second that's a really good
score for an ultrabook
like this but the razer we got
48.1 frames per second
so even though we only had a 15 to 16
percent difference
in the geekbench 5 graphics test
here the macbook is 65
higher in terms of frames per second so
as far as far as
optimized gaming goes the macbook is far
ahead now of course this is one test
it's a benchmark
and with windows you have access to a
bunch of games you don't have to do
any workarounds crossover you don't have
to wait all the games are ready
but as far as the performance it still
gets smoked
by the mac and as far as gaming
performance on battery power i ran it
again
the razer is actually identical 48.1 it
didn't change
the macbook actually got higher by about
1 fps which is
interesting but it is great to see that
and now
we're going to step into more
performance and we'll see
does this actually correlate when you're
running both the cpu and the gpu
first i want to really push these
systems with cinebench r20 which is
going to max out the cpus we're also
going to do some thermal testing
and i'm going to open up my hardware
monitor here and i want to see what
wattage you have okay 40
45 46 48 49 watts
it keeps going up here that is the limit
and as far as frequency running at
just basically four gigahertz wow 50
watts so we're definitely drawing a lot
of power
but the temps 95 96 degrees celsius
97.98
are we going to hit 199 100 on one of
the cores
fans just kicked up really hard our mac
is at 78 degrees celsius the fan
is still off and it looks like the razer
is now thermal throttling we're running
at 3.6 gigahertz now
so it is slowing down because of heat
whereas our macbook it runs at a
consistent 13 watts
and there's no thermal throttling it
runs at 3.2 gigahertz when you're giving
it a full load
let's take a look with our thermal
camera it looks like our macbook's
running at 32 degrees celsius
at its hottest point and the razor is at
39 degrees celsius there's a lot more
hot spots overall
but we also have a couple of cool spots
and that's where the fans are sucking in
cool air
two and a half minutes in and our mac is
now running at 96 degrees celsius
94 and the fans kicked up but only at
2700 rpm it's still completely
silent and with that those are the
performance cores that run
hot and apple is okay with them running
hot as long as the system is silent
the uh the power efficiency cores are
running really cool and
that's about as hot as they get over
there we're five minutes in and i have
to say i am impressed with this razor
for two reasons
after it cools down it kicks the wattage
back up now we're at 36 watts from 25
and the frequencies go up as well
whereas
most other windows laptops with these
same processors
they just slowly go down to 20 watts
we're almost done let's take one more
glance with the thermal camera we have
39 degrees
all concentrated there right in the
center of the keyboard
and we have 43 44
on the razor all right we are finished
and the
macbook gets a score of 76.74
in our razor blade let's close this 54
44. honestly i thought it was gonna be
higher
because of how high those frequencies
stayed and the wattage kept going up
so that is very interesting i guess
that's still about 13 percent better
than the dell xps so that's a good
improvement
but the m1 mac is 40 faster
in full cpu load which is a pretty
substantial difference
now i still want to go ahead and unplug
these and i'm just going to run one
single test so
it's not going to completely factor in
thermal throttling
but we'll see what kind of difference we
get on battery wow it's still
boosting the 50 watts on battery power
let me kick up the brightness here so
you guys can see that
so on battery it's still allowing it
access to the full
power 51 watts that it can get
but then it quickly does drop down there
you go 19 watts
so it doesn't stay there very long and
our frequency instead of
4 gigahertz now we're at 2.7 or so
of course the mac it runs completely the
same
regardless we have our scores and
interesting so
it looks like the multi-core score is
actually higher
than before now i'm sure if this was a
long test it would be a little bit lower
but really not by much with the dell xps
it went from 4800 down to 4200
with just a single run on battery power
we're here we actually went a little bit
higher so
that is excellent and with that i want
to say that the fans are not that
loud they're definitely quieter than the
dells
as well so as far as thermals
it is pretty good really good for a
windows laptop and now
let's get into photo editing i have
lightroom classic opened up here
of course this is an x86 app perfect for
this intel
razer book and with the m1 rosetta has
to translate it so it's not running at
full performance
and we have 50 42 megapixel raw images
open up here with a bunch of effects i'm
going to click the develop tab on both
and wow the razer was almost instant
there let's go back to library
bam the razer is quicker again on the
xps they're about the same
and now let's go ahead and scroll
through these images these
42 megapixel images they are tough on
system so let's click next
okay the mac is actually faster
that was quite a bit faster there that
was about the same
mac is faster very interesting as you
guys see i have a lot of changes here
let's go ahead and do a quick zoom test
and do you hear that the razor's fans
although it was quiet in the past it's
running and
it's off on the m1 so let's go ahead and
click
we'll zoom into the center over here
same performance on both and now let's
go into
our brushes here all right
nice and smooth no lag
at all let's try out our
m1 mac little bit of lag right there at
the start if you guys saw that
yep tiny bit of lag at the start and
then it smooths out
perfectly smooth so the razor is a
little bit better as far as brushes
dealing with these images
and now let's go ahead and export 50 of
these
images i have my timer ready
hit start and let's go the fans are
kicking in
on the razer let's check our hardware
monitor yep
98 degrees 97 100 degrees and not much
later
the razor finishes so as far as overall
performance when we're exporting these
images
they're fairly close we have two minutes
and 35 seconds
for the mac and two minutes and 55
seconds for the razer
so about 20 seconds faster on the mac of
course this application is not yet
optimized
i assume once they optimize it we're
gonna get faster speeds
and then as far as brushes it's gonna be
perfectly smooth so now let's do one
more test with photo editing and this is
gonna be
building one-to-one previews all right
very very interesting i feel like i said
interesting so many times in this video
so when we exported the images there was
only about a 20 second
difference but creating one-to-one
previews
the macbook took two minutes and 21
seconds
compared to three minutes and 33 seconds
so instead of just a small difference
the gap there is
much bigger so the macbook is about i
don't know 35
40 faster than that scenario very
interesting i went ahead and opened up a
4k project in premiere pro
now my previous videos i tested final
cut which is super well optimized for m1
and davinci resolve where they've
started do optimizations
but it's still nowhere near as good as
final cut at least
for now and premiere is actually not
optimized
for the m1 at all whatsoever it's
optimized
for x86 systems like the razer book so
i thought it'd be interesting just
because premiere pro is the most popular
video editing
platform let's go ahead and hit play
with this project here
and this is full 4k on both i have two
luts applied i have some film grain
and it looks like ah they're very
similar i might actually have a little
bit more
glitchiness over here this is perfectly
smooth
the razor's starting to kick up its fans
i went ahead and enabled
dog ears here and that just shows us all
this
info and yep i was right i could trust
my eyes we're playing back at 20
19 20 frames per second instead of 30.
so basically we're dropping about a
third of the frames and i could tell
it's stuttery
now let's take a look at the mac right
about 30 29
all right so almost perfect playback at
full 4k
resolution and this is pretty much what
most youtubers are editing
and the codecs they're using and typical
effects so it looks like the mac
it's playing back perfectly smooth i
can't tell any issues at full quality
and completely silent without heating up
the razor's heating up
and it's dropping about a third of the
frames very interesting so let's go
ahead and export
this five minute project i'm using adobe
media encoder
and right off the bat the mac started
exporting
fairly quickly we're still waiting on
this to initiate
there we go it's running now let's just
wait for these to finish
all right guys we are done and i once
again wasn't expecting this
um the razer took 12 minutes and 32
seconds
compared to 9 minutes and 55
seconds so the razer took about two and
a half
minutes longer to finish this test i
thought that the macbook pro
gets smoked we're running premiere pro
which is not optimized
at all with that if we were running
davinci resolve
um this macbook actually in our last
test took five minutes and two seconds
the same exact identical project
so basically twice as fast if we're
running davinci resolve
and with the dell xps that has the same
exact components that took
12 minutes and 50 seconds so actually
slightly slower than premiere
looks like it's about the same time and
if you're running final cut the same
project takes
three minutes and four seconds to do
so here's a little graph for you guys
wow
so let me go ahead and unplug you i'll
run that again well judging off of the
estimated time
and premiere is fairly accurate here uh
it's gonna take exactly the same time we
have 12 minutes remaining
it's been 34 seconds here so it looks
like if you're unplugged
you still get the same performance which
is fantastic for a windows laptop
alright guys so what is my final verdict
well
first off i did not expect the razer to
perform so well
this is their first productivity laptop
and not only does it look great
it's sleek the screen is very
nice it's bright it's not very
reflective yes the color accuracy isn't
as good as the mac
but with that it just impressed me so
much more than i expected
the fan noise is lower than dell's i
like to design better
you can swap out the ssd in here it
doesn't lose
much performance at all when you're on
battery power it is faster
this is just a really really sweet
machine
now with that the mac is actually
cheaper
which is crazy this is about 100 cheaper
if you spec it out
it has a higher resolution screen
brightness is similar you have better
color accuracy the speaker is
smoke the razer it is faster
even in programs like lightroom and
premiere pro
which are not optimized and that is just
very very impressive and of course if
you use optimized applications it's even
better
and then it is pretty much silent even
under full load when the fans are
spinning it's super
quiet most of time the fans stay off and
then
battery life is something we didn't talk
about with this system here
with the razer the 1080p option you
could expect about
six to maybe eight hours with real world
usage
mixed usage whereas the macbook pro
you're looking
above 15 hours for real world mixed
usage so the battery life is absolutely
incredible on the mac
so if you know that you want a windows
laptop if as long as you don't need
great speakers i would highly highly
recommend this razer
i'm going to be using it more testing it
out and then we're going to do a full
review on it
and if you don't care about operating
systems you don't need windows
the mac is a such a sweet deal for the
performance you're getting and
everything else
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section i have links to both
down below
click that circle above to subscribe and
check out one of those other great
videos right over there
and i will see you guys in the next
video
[Music]